[Music]
in emoji battle news
oh she submitted by send nudes emojis
are showing up in court cases and the
courts aren't prepared to know how to
deal with them that's hilarious
using it as evidence like in the
discovery mile and then they did the
crappie and then I did that okay I was
picturing like he murdered someone
oh okay oh [ __ ] sorry you know when you
guys used to buy like me back in the day
like you know like people always tapping
their phones that was illegal you're
kind of talking like different call you
have grass or you have whatever super
paranoid for the stupidest read yeah
you're just super paranoid nobody gives
a [ __ ] if you wonder texting or texting
around it you're like hey oh we're gonna
go to that being like you're just
texting all around but then whatever a
conversation you guys are having back
and forth you guys know what we're
talking about are they using emojis now
to go next level I'm just putting those
together yeah so here's an example this
is happening in the Bay Area the these
prosecutors are trying to prove that
this man was arrested during a
prostitution sting that he was guilty of
pimping charges so they said that their
evidence was Instagram DMS where he sent
a woman and one of them said teamwork
make the dream work and then he added
high heels and a money bag emoji at the
end so then that's like said him being
so that means something in the online
pimp world isn't there a pimp emoji it
looks like it yeah like a Michael
Jackson floating [ __ ] yeah and he's
like a pimp coat and a [ __ ] hat
trying to avoid that that's too easy
what you want to know yeah I think so we
isn't it a purple suit yeah I feel like
I've seen it so these kids gotta be
careful because they might be just using
random emojis but it could be criminal
lingo Alec so wait are they just like
are they gonna scan and see like hey you
used eggplant emoji like did are you
your pasta to purchaser eggplant emoji
and money bag who you're gonna take you
in yeah there's a disco guy but he's not
I thought it was the other one with the
hat next to the disco the Hat right here
this guy I thought I was a skinny
pilgrim loading yeah yeah the skinny
boom like slender man with the [ __ ]
hat on I mean I thought he was like a
men in black person oh they make these
emojis no no no they're Jeff but what
better way looks like a skinny pilgrim
really japanese people made emojis yeah
i didn't know that i thought i phone
people made the emoji no i finally
bought it because before you used to
have to download a separate keyboard
from the app store
look they're only Japanese monuments
there's like shrines the techmount foods
ramen and curry and although I thought
they're being so multicultural and [ __ ]
we don't got no yeah we do have no idea
but back in the day they did they only
had weird like Japanese specific because
if you type in full of different kind of
noodles come out now it's like you don't
know Dalls or whatever and if you type
in like ramen the ramen noodles come out
was like whoa yeah what do you think
it's the least used emoji oh there's a
lot of random ones in there the grandma
grandpa no no the gay grandpa it's like
one of those like stop lasers like a
stop light the gay grandpa's making out
that one and their finger being a chance
but yeah that's what that one doesn't
get I use that one but not what we get
used ironically okay but there's like
random ones like like random where you
don't even know what they are they're
like buildings of things that you're
like what the [ __ ] is that
and I'm always like why would I send a
giraffe I don't understand there's no
dress
there's a draft there is yeah I like to
animate [ __ ] is the [ __ ] you don't you
just deny that there's times though that
I feel like the updates and watching
that and then I look for it and it
doesn't exist I'm like I could have
sworn I seen an emoji for this thing I
can't think of an example but hospital
ones not that fun well they're always at
inland he's ready
just like instinctively being like no
look you in real life we don't care
you're always very certain and wrong so
on Saturday at precisely 1:00 o'clock
but this only happens once every
thousand lot no it hasn't gone that
thousand times so so tiff is taking a
trip to Iceland and it's his fault since
we've traveled in the snow
we were already equipped because we were
out in his stuff for what like ten days
and we were very comfortable and it was
good - we were like well hey why don't
we all just go to REI together and then
we can just pick whatever layers that
you need to buy so then um we got all
her stuff taken care of and now we had
to take care of KC stuff and I'm kind of
looking through my Instagram back when
we were using our gear to see what Bart
was wearing just I could be sure and I
look and I tell TIFF this is Bart was
nowhere in sight at this point so you
take care of typhoid a bit father
we're just being a good father hope
that's enough crime so then I look at
her and I'm like oh shoot
case needs to get a vest because look in
this picture Bart's wearing the vest and
a jacket so that tells me it must've
been really cold so then Bart comes back
and we're about to get all of Casey
stuff and when I can make sure to get
Casey vest and he goes what I'm not
gonna need a vest I never wore vice I'm
like yeah you wore a vest he's like I
never wore a vest like you or the vet
collegio I've never
I love that I never wore vests you wore
vests and I'm like no you wore vests
he's like show me a picture oh my God
he's [ __ ] wrapping this for me and a
bow was there she was my height Maggie
she just looked at she's listening to
him as she looked at me she was like you
was living through me in that moment
that's the worse when there's witnesses
because then your whole Drive back from
the trip they could talk about what a
dumb [ __ ] you are super sick forever
immortalized because now there's this
video and I showed him the picture and
he had nothing to say to be the good
father
it was nutsack went into and he had a
vagina for this we got in an argument
while we were making a video one time
and I was like oh yeah we got into a
screaming argument there's no [ __ ]
way this is true is over some stupid
[ __ ] in this court of public opinion
and then she plays everything and I'm
like I don't [ __ ] believe it I say in
the video is like when I'm Kezia he'll
say one thing and he says the opposite
and like why would you say the opposite
thing you just said that and then we
start getting an actual argument and
then I'm like why are you making me feel
crazy I'm not crazy cuz he's doing this
thing where he's like I would never say
that like why would I say that when they
say you never first say that like for
obviously I was joking never say that I
would never wear [ __ ] best
so what is your best go I mean it's put
away somewhere but he had it is the most
important part of that story is you were
supposed to lend your vest to Casey
no no we were at REI buying stuff but I
was proving to bar that Casey is gonna
need a vest because it gets that cool
even like you need to find that best so
you can let taste it's just like hey I
think you need a vest no he doesn't
victory was so [ __ ] sweet
Casey's a grown man and he could decide
for himself if he needs to go I don't
like people discussing if Casey needs a
vest or no okay she's just like he's not
even there no it was just it was just me
telling Bart that he needs to hook Casey
yeah because he's gonna be cold so I
made a good friend I'm really hard to
expect it's really close ever been that
hooking him up I yeah yeah that's what I
was thinking is like oh he's gonna let
him borrow his vest case you'd say Casey
you need a vest top speed of hookups we
just hooked up Jess
cuz this video is called emoji cries
Casey needs a vest
always right that's like have to go to a
separate site to add them heels and
money bags together probably though nope
that means Constitution one time I was
walking around in New York and this guy
was like Green Day tickets white striped
tickets Green Day ticket I was like oh
[ __ ] the Green Day and white striper
play and it was code for drugs it was
like marijuana or cocaine I had no I was
like I thought he was selling quite you
know because my friend that was with me
was I was like [ __ ] greedy and white
stripes are play that's crazy
she's like mom she's like no he says
that cuz those bands suck it nobody
thinks would do anyone would buy those
tickets
great day of white stripes give up the
drug dealers I'm sorry yeah I was
walking on Haight Street and someone's
like do you know Alice and I'm like no
no Alice I was like why do you ask me if
I knew Alice
Steve I was walking I was walking in
Bali going to get Nicky some pain meds
or something for cramps and I'm walking
around I think and the guys like you
want a let's eat you want cocaine for
there were some Australian kids that got
locked up immediately if they find any
sort of drugs on you you're like in jail
doc then and he just did a shitty job
he's like a white guy oh I'm gonna get
him we were in Mexico and we're just
there's this old man with like a car and
he was like selling sandwiches and they
were like oh what is this and don't you
gonna ask him what are you selling
clothes or just algae's bread water
dulce I've heard what else he said he
goes like somebody's Molly's are like
Mexican food probably pedaling away he
goes we so you can smoke weed and take a
bike you selling the munchies and
believe good business oh yeah well now
in California I wonder if they'll start
doing those cafes like they have where
you can like smoke and they sell food
they do have one already yeah I heard
that they were gonna try to do pairings
like how they do wine pairings what's
your food yeah it's gonna be a type of
cannabis and then to Taco Bell that you
want me after you [ __ ] your brains out
like stuff this beer in your mouth yeah
oh you're gonna be hungry
Josh sounds delicious they're gonna have
wine in the store I would do it I would
do that yeah yeah I would yeah it's just
[ __ ] fun telling ya I want del Taco
you always with this deltaw question so
divisive you wonder why you have this
[ __ ] all the time
[Music]